hello I'm gonna stuff a good guy
remember it so you don't have to well
ever since I did my princess hate video
I kind of maybe sorta said I do Bridge
to Terabithia at some point the
responses have ranged from oh boy when
are you gonna do that to if you touch
that timeless treasure I will impale
your testicles on a set of toothpicks ha
joke's on you I haven't felt any
feelings out there because it seems like
this
well I not want to disagree with other
people's opinions unless they're stupid
and not mine this is Bridge to
Terabithia based on the beloved
children's novel from the 70s Disney
decided to use this story as a means of
realizing that their family death toll
is a little too high at least in age we
can kill them younger
can't we isn't that our goal to show
kids what a beautiful world it is by
making them realize death can take it
away from them at any moment and you
wish upon the Reapers come in bitches hi
let's be fair that's not the only reason
to find it underwhelming the others well
let's take a look at Bridge to
Terabithia we open with our main
character named Jess played by Josh
Hutcherson who lives next to a
greenhouse run by his father Robert
Patrick still upset he'll never be
allowed to do a role as good as the
t1000 but at least he's been working as
red-green impression i make him to say
all these vegetables are part of our
livelihood yeah chores none you ever
notice how whining your window down by
hand makes you look lower middle class
just was getting ready to participate in
a track race today the only downside he
doesn't have the right shoes I could
hardly call him sneakers anymore I throw
them out what there's a perfectly good
old pair of Brenda's I mean these are
girls ones oh come on just write
friendship is magic on the side at least
the bronies will leave you alone are you
excited about your first day of school
yeah yeah you stink Hey
stinkies Wow apparently the movie is
already so bored too decided to follow
an ant that's bad sign but just as
planned to cover up his shoes doesn't
work as that's not bully gang is ready
to pounce on it
sweet sneaks in you wear your sister's
hand-me-down underwear to be PBB PBB
know what that is
Milan was your detector um zing he asked
you a question twinkle toes you did whoo
I hold my insults towards after-school
specials of the 80s actually this does
bring up one of the major problems with
the movie the book was written in the
70s which is fine but if you're gonna
update to present-day
you have to do exactly that update it
and some of the dialogue here is clearly
very dated I mean once the last time you
ever heard a kid say dead meat but this
kid acts like it's the holy grail of
insults that nobody will ever be able to
top him on listen to him he's obsessed
with the phrase goods dead meat oh I'm
so texting that's inured to my friend
yeah I know oh we don't see the entrance
of our other lead Lesley played by
annasophia robb who I swear is the first
human being to be physically
photoshopped to look like a plastic
Disney product I'm serious look at her
just make a toy out of that face it'll
sell I don't use my Barbie so much
anymore if you want you can have him
think what do I need them for I am the
Barbie she's like a compiled mentalis
tars to create the ultimate in purified
Disney unholiness I hear there's even a
plot among the Disney Princesses to take
away all her enchanted perfections first
we'll start with her cheekbones
yes then a perfect little eyes Ariel
deal with it
what is she just as perfect and
endearing as the other Disney female
leads does this movie like to dress
their heroines like an imploding Punky
Brewster
but wait I'm wearing girl shoes Jen I
like absorb their power so it turns out
Leslie lives right next door to Jess but
he doesn't let that quirky nothing wrong
with her and s get the best of him as
he's got the hots for someone else a
teacher played by Zooey Deschanel star
of the hit television show filler after
the Mindy project
check her white his friends for listings
are you sure this movie wasn't meant to
be called bridge to non offense eeeh
this world is so blamele upbeat I swear
it was a gun commercial
really Disney you don't have enough
money for backing that you had to go to
juicy fruit juicy fruit the gum of
contrived unmotivated Disney moments
everywhere well just still has the hots
for 500 days of bland as he does find
his interest in Leslie does seem to grow
as he finds out more about her
especially when the teacher calls her up
to read the paper she's very fond of
entitled self-contained underwater
breathing apparatus by Leslie Burke Wow
um this reading brought to you by the
incredibly ironic Institute of polling
assure collars going yellow and floating
in silence above me there's nothing but
shimmery light the place where I have
come from and we'll go back to when I am
done here oh come on this is like John
Bob it's favorite song being walk like a
man we're a school of silverfish wait as
I swing through the water bubbles burst
for me
wobbling like little jellyfish as they
rise and what does his father grow in
his greenhouse again actually this would
be an interesting idea if he fantasized
like this as the credits make it look
like that's actually sore the angle
they're going for like maybe his drawing
is the visual style of his fantasy but
strangely enough the rest of the movie
is done with 3d CGI so this is the only
time this style is ever used yeah kind
of inconsistent huh it's like it for
some reason I change up styles in the
middle of review to reflect something
like Frank Miller hey Samuel Jackson I'm
a Nazi for some reason I won no way
question that he starts to hang out with
Leslie more and more and they find they
have quite the rapport and by rapport I
mean she says something enchanting and
he stares at her with all
okay do we have a name for this look you
know this one that dumbass expression
when someone says something that the
movie obviously wants to shove in your
face was magical so the given awkward
quiet pause do we have a name for that
please
whimsical digestion those painful
moments where a character has to reflect
on just how wonder is the movie they're
in it
reach the end of the road on your mark
set go come on over here is a moment
anyone not going through a midlife
crisis would fine pointlessly endearing
Oh Rawlings magical
Hey look at that cool that's been there
forever I wouldn't trust it with
foreshadowing music like that I think we
could call it the death rope
okay even as enchanted moments go this
is really pushing it's a frigging rope
when you look back on childhood you
might see this as something more
remarkably innocent but when you're a
kid it's a friggin roll let your head
hang back watch the clouds
well maybe Jess can pop some sense into
her overly whimsical
it's fucking everything gonna be like
this it's every little mundane thing
going to be an incredible adventure of
laughs and whimsy imagine if I did every
little mundane thing like this
Oh
if we really have to go well it's so
whimsical in here live your childhood
fantasy somewhere else
you guys are so naughty chanting so
Leslie being so inspiring Lee Wow
suggest that they make up their own
little world you need a place just for
us but if there is a magical kingdom
that only we knew about when we can use
a ton of false advertising to trick
Narnia fans into seeing Leslie wait up
hell your talk of obvious fictional
worlds in a public forest during the
incredibly sunny daytime is scaring me
what am I looking for exactly just close
your eyes keep your mind wide open
we call this place Terabithia I'm so
perfect and inspired I came up with that
fitting name and we'll try I also have
an idea for a young adult series they
ripped off battle royale sounds trite
Leslie continues to make up details
about her fictional world but is it me
or is her dedication sounding less
charming and more psychotically specific
too bad for them they got so close what
are you talking about to the kingdom
what's that that's the sound of
prisoners rattling their chain what
prisoners the prisoners of the Dark
Master
Jeff you and I have been sent to freedom
prisoners of the Dark Master we have
come to free you see I'm up there yeah
do you really yeah maybe a little too
into our little world aren't we warriors
try dragonflies no they're warriors we
were all terrified yeah and nothing
crushes us you better not let the
terabithians hear you I don't know this
game what game this is for real why do I
see years later a very disturbing
reunion when they meet up again Leslie
thank you so much for dinner you know
it's so good to see you been doing so
well after all these years of course
yeah yeah takes me back to when we were
little kids oh hey remember that uh
fantasy where we made up when we were
younger Terabithia yeah yeah yeah those
are magical times man how we used to
pretend we used to live there what are
you talking about
still there what the terabithians miss
you Jess they would like their King to
rule with their queen once more oh wow
look at the time
oh I gotta go do some same things away
from you let me show you more about
their vision please I'm hungry and I
need food
this is where the evil trolls lived do
you see no you see oh there's nothing
there their blade slides oh dear the
terabithians are telling me that someone
might need another scrotum waxing I mean
yes yes sexy I see oh good I thought
you'd be like all the others that didn't
see oh we rule Terabithia and nothing
crushes us
you
so sadly both our stars have to return
to the real world where things still
seem less than perfect though to be fair
still pretty damn close to perfect don't
you think we should give our hand she's
fine
hey P P P P fuck Oh never change that
joke never do any variation with it I
don't know where it is my is just
timeless you just got it you got this
the perfection of laughter and there one
little collection of words Oh
ingenious absolutely ingenious I give it
up and this could be your future pal
just Aaron stripped me on purpose
okay Aaron's if the role he didn't do
anything oh you have your magical
kingdom you're in charge of well I have
my plus world where I can throw any kid
off with no legal repercussions
whatsoever don't mess with the king baby
buzz well but they still managed to find
peace in their fictional realm where
friggin everything seems to amaze them
how come you're so good at that
good at what building stuff me she'll
really get it for a girl
I mean hammering a nail into a door
fucking witchcraft but even their world
at times can come crashing down
giant troll Oh will you shut up already
we almost died
squirrels sneaky footsoldiers it's a
dark mask let's cut up and their teeny
weeny stomachs and feet are there many
little entrails damn it but just decides
his world isn't Rockwell Ian enough a
pointless animal sidekick we'll fix that
up as he adopts a dog out of nowhere and
just gives it to Leslie yeah kind of
random how do you think the parents feel
about that well apparently they're just
as everlastingly perfect as she is so of
course they don't mind don't believe me
just look at how downright utopian these
loaves of Wonderbread off I'm determined
to have this well finish so when the
late Sun hits it we can watch it catch
fire
now that's one steady hand Jessen that's
an artist's hand am i right you know the
best prize that Life offers is the
chance to work hard at work worth doing
as Teddy Roosevelt said that it's just
like my parents said before they left
Bethlehem son do your best to cure
cancer hug puppies and quilts collars
with impeccable articulation
Christ can this will get any more sappy
or small t Oh God
stop it you're making full house look
like a hole cut drama masters
you think you can
you soo young
so
you find do you
Wow what did I tell you
was it worth it well we suck as painters
but at least we rock as a Sears catalog
commercial don't dance out again so now
the dog is in their fictional world
which their imaginations seem to make
more and more real by the day ticklish
old toe jam
we should probably feed the dog no he's
a magic dog that doesn't need food and
can fly off cliffs whenever we taught in
that doesn't sound okay be a god damn it
this fictional world I guess strengthens
their courage as they stand up to
bullies who bought people's entrances
into the bathroom
are there no adults in this fucking
school that's not fair is it Ping's
definitely supposed to be free free free
the P the free to be movement was born
first they moved to Russia and they
migrated to China too in the world
fought back against the evil come you
piss you haven't gone pick a fight with
him
thank you but kid no I'm a kicked out of
school for fighting a girl what's that
gonna prove but they figure out another
way to get back at her they forge a love
letter from a boy she likes and she
actually believes it's from him making a
fool of herself in front of everybody
did it will it no he's totally in love
with you
okay
his sister enjoyed that a little too
much that wasn't just a funny little
moment that was Count of Monte Cristo
style vengeance Oh her tears of despair
fuel my inner goddess but they find out
that maybe their joke went too far as
they start to feel sad for the bully and
even managed to get some interesting
information out of her dad gets really
mad at her he hits her it got out well
what did you say to her I told her just
to pretend that she had no idea what
anyone was talking about and in a few
weeks time everybody would just forget
about it then I gave her pretty dumb
oh well I do hope it was juicy fruit gum
it is the old mighty Savior juicy fruit
why call the police when you have gum
then get this they actually decide to
bring religion into the mix yeah I know
I'm scared to Sunday we go to church can
I hug you David no
um girls can't wear pants
Jeff girls can't wear pants uh look guys
I don't know when's the last time you've
been to church but unless you worship at
Our Lady of Donna Reed I don't think
this is an issue but bizarrely enough
even they're fictional world starts to
play a part here - hey they are honoring
a carpenter who brought people back to
life entering water into wine no talk of
magic will be allowed in here
Oh God
quick pull the religious leaders of the
world I got an email option the likes of
antigen has never seen good and to make
things even more awkward they start
talking about their religious experience
on the way back just remember guys the
last time Disney tried to talk about
religion we got a perverted old man
jerking off to a sexy fireplace unless
you plan to turn this into a creepy ass
song number tread lightly if you don't
believe the Bible Donald damn it oh hell
when you die that's right haja god
damned to hell if you don't think but
okay can I just say that forgiving
Disney for the Jonas Brothers has made a
little bit easier when they have a small
child say God damns you to hell several
times in their kids movie
god damn hell god damn it hell goddamn
hell
I seriously do not think God goes around
damning people to hell he's too busy
running all this whimsy and speaking of
which we have even more whimsy to
partake in as yet another trip down
imagination Lane takes place yeah open
this oh she says she won't let me free
unless I convert to Judaism but oh no
more poorly CG monsters off the port
dumb Wow
we suck even in our own fantasies I
can't be cool anywhere what
you know here's my problem with these
fantasies if they were really using them
to solve their problems are tied in more
to the story I could forgive them more
but apart from a monster having a
bullies voice or a bullies face there's
no other connection to anything going on
so the movie just sort of stops dead in
his tracks for these scenes that have no
suspense because we know it's not real
and no investment because we're not
learning anything about how much more
interesting would have been if they sat
down and talked with the troll who
looked like a bully or maybe some of
their adventures were connected to the
real-life worries wouldn't that be more
dramatic wouldn't that be more
interesting but no they use it to
green-screen a background of them
running against a forest witch why
didn't you just film them running
against a forest he'll catch us Leslie
what a bastard
at the end of the day they go back home
and say goodbye to one another yeah
you
well I sure hope nothing bad happens to
either them after the totally random
goodbye that isn't in any way being
embellished for any reason whatsoever
okay we got enough returned the Jedi
jokes
the next day Jess gets a call from his
music teacher and sees if he wants to go
alone with her downtown to an art museum
and yes that sounds exactly as creepy to
you as it does to me
I know it's a Saturday but it's your
teacher miss Edmund planning on taking
my nephew's into the city to the museum
and my sister plans last-minute so I had
a thought
again I don't know if this was a more
acceptable thing during the 70s but
nowadays this would raise some serious
red flags don't believe me try watching
it with this music instead witness the
horror witness the terror witness a
famous actor playing that scary role
every famous actor wants to play at
least once in their career Zooey
Deschanel Hunger Games joke
the field trip brought to you by Disney
mine like yours wide open you could
create a whole new world give I'm sick
to death of these forced whimsical
moments can't once just something going
credibly wrong in this movie I got a
chance huh where God's name have you
been well good somebody better be dead
your friend Leslie's dead send your
angry emails to nostalgia critic a idiot
with bad timing calm Yanks they killed
her off I mean damn she drowned in a
creek this one apparently she tried to
swing across on a rope and it broke well
I'm sure they'll do a lot of more the
todd romanticizing with his - what does
he have flashbacks of seeing her or like
her spirit in the forest or something
actually to the movies credit the
majority of the film dealing with the
death scene is handled pretty maturely
he goes through denial over his best
friend being gone takes long silent
walks by himself snaps at his sister
even the fantasy world plays an
interesting role he sees a dark spirit
heading towards him that he tries to run
away from which is really his father
forcing him to confront the reality of
her passing resulting in him finally
breaking down it wasn't there to go with
her it's my fault where were these
scenes earlier this is really effective
well for the most part there's still one
or two moments that still seem a bit
heavy-handed for example what song are
they singing in class the next day
come on okay kids next we'll be singing
the happy songs of hull floats under the
sea and rolling down the river Jess you
look sad for some reason so it looks
like it's fastest kid in the class now
huh oh no no he did not he did not look
there's not an enigma and that was not
no no no okay normally I wouldn't say
that violence is the solution but in
this test I say definitely choose answer
f4 fuck his ass up don't make him get
out his cake decorating kit hey kid
sorry about your friend now get off I
don't want to evil spirits haunting my
domain that's world but speaking of
bridges he decides to build one for
himself obviously learning from that
sorcery she taught him with hammering
nails into wood he builds his own bridge
and decides to bring his sister into his
fantasy world and sure enough her
imagination allows them to once again
see the exact same vision somehow the
future are you the changes and if your
princess wait does that technically make
me your daughter my best friend is dead
and my teachers hitting on me I don't
know what's normal anymore
and to top off this story about
realizing life by accepting death how
about a completely unfitting up-tempo
pop song
your best friend died your world is
unlike you ask your God in a bag please
why and you know doesn't this music kind
of sum up what's wrong with the movie I
give it credit for what it's trying to
do and for actually succeeding in some
areas the death scene is handled well
the fact that our two leads aren't
romantically involved is very rare and
the idea of creating a world to cope
with the harshness of life is not a bad
one but the dialogue needed to be
updated the whimsical tone is just too
over-the-top and a story like this only
works if the kids act like real kids not
like unrealistic heavenly archetypes
that are only made that way so you can
feel more bad when one of them dies
imagine if the death scene of a child
happened in say the Sandlot or To Kill a
Mockingbird it would have been much more
effective because you identified with
these characters because they were
written as normal kids not angelic
memories of being a kid so what would
have hit you a lot harder but when you
make them too perfect they don't seem
real and therefore they're harder to
feel for when something as heavy as this
happens to them so while I don't think
it's among one of the worst movies I've
seen as some parts did get it right I
don't think you fully understood that
fun little moments should just be
portrayed as fun little moments instead
of the most important whimsical
experiences life has to offer though to
be fair it does make everyday activity
seem a lot more exciting I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember so you don't
have to
0:01 edition for college humor yeah
Vivian goddammit
you
goddamn to hell